okay six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty we have dozens of
people holding Wow it is a big day on
the phones dozens of people holding but
next someone who is no longer holding is
our caller from the five one three area
code five one three tell us who you are
and tell us what's on your mind today
hey David this is Alisa med well okafor
and I'm calling from Cincinnati Ohio all
right as you may know the Ohio voter
purge situation went to the Supreme
Court today and Secretary of State Jon
Husted he's being heard by the Supreme
Court about the situation so I'm not
sure if you've been following it but
basically Ohio has been practicing to
use it or lose it methods for voting
where if you haven't voted in two years
yet the send a notification or some kind
of postcard to confirm your address and
if you don't do so the Secretary of
State's office they just pretty much
kick off the people without further
notice and many people have said that
this is a clear violation of the
National Voter Registration Act so I
just wanted to hear your thoughts on the
whole situation and if the Supreme Court
rules you know that it's illegal what do
you think would happen to Secretary of
State in Ohio I'm John Huston yeah well
nothing will happen to them there's
rarely ever real repercussions to people
who engage in this type of voter
suppression usually you just have to
undo whatever regulation or provision
you've you've put in place that a court
decides is not okay yeah I think it's a
disaster I think that if you if there is
not a an issue of you know double
registration which even in and of itself
to me the problem is double voting not
double registration but even that you
could sort of make the case like well if
you can identify that it's the same
person and not two people with the same
name which by the way Indiana as an
example tells us you can't always do
then you could make a case for removing
one of those people but as a general
principle I am against the removal of
people from the voter rolls merely
because they've not voted for two years
or two election cycles or whatever the
case may be and I'm against really all
of the voter suppression tactics that
are out there usually they're there
framed as being a response to or a
protection to a protection from the in
person voter fraud that the Wright
claims exists of course it doesn't exist
there's no evidence that it exists any
more than a handful of people per
election cycle and oftentimes the
Republicans trying to find a prove the
system's no good even that Commission
that Trump started to voter fraud right
with Kris Kobach and Mike Pence yeah
they had to disband that because they
weren't getting anywhere with yeah well
they claim it's because the states
weren't cooperating but of course there
was no evidence that was the the real
problem so yeah I mean I'm following
that I don't know what ultimately will
be the rule but I think no matter what
if you're waiting around for Jon Husted
to end up in prison I mean I just don't
think anything's gonna happen to him
yeah he's actually running for
lieutenant governor in Ohio so he might
be running away from the whole situation
just because of that well I don't know
yeah
all right well we'll watch it thank you
for the comment all yep no problem at
all all right and on that note let's
take a quick break and we will be back
with more calls next at six one seven
eight three zero
4750